vor allem an wie das hier nicht mehr
eine hexe sieht man das selber schuld
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück zu christus glaubt
hohoho meine lieben frau hat mir
geschrieben aber etwa die man ab dessen
traurig und ein gegner kommt
wahrscheinlich in der nächsten folge
dazu weil diese stehen überall rosen
warum weil ich eine kleine nacht stunde
vorbereitet habe ich möchte mich jetzt
schlafen
natürlich schmeckt den raum dafür ein
wenig aus damit wir es beide romantisch
und das ja süß von der iaea also meine
lieben freunde heute ist der zweite
advent weiter dezember ob ich schnell
die zeit vergeht haltefrist einmal
bezahlt eine presse okay okay es geht
wieder los die kräfte also erst abwarten
was von überhaupt dieser folge machen
weil der höhe oder eine vernünftige ok
höhlentour erst mal wenn wir uns jetzt
hier equipment holen also
also nur nur ist das alte ich habe dass
ich habe das nie du ich hab das eisen
ich muss erst mal zwei schwerter nicht
machen uns ein schwert einer doku reisen
einer bekommt eisen schwert und einer
bekannten dings und einer hand kommt nur
glaube ich vier eisen oder stimmte das
nicht ich hab dafür eisen reingepackt
auf jeden fall das heißt rein
theoretische einer von uns beiden dürfte
reisen haben ich habe kein eisen hast
reisen
hast du stärker für mich ein 82 wanne
weil da machen wir ich würde sagen eine
eisen spitzhacke und ein eisen schwert
damit wir so sachen so wertvolle sache
noch abbauen könnten war steht will dann
bekomme ich das schwert
kommen wir schicken das postgebäude
ich hatte schaufel gebucht dadurch
kommen eine willkommene schaufeln und du
bekommst dichtauf im moment moment
du kommst du hier noch das andere weise
so jetzt haben wir nur der taufe ernst
und kein schwert nö
ok es gut dass man jetzt aber kann es
mal ein schwert vergeben hat es
weggeworfen und also er hier dankeschön
wird einfach weg
wir hätten mit spitzer glücklich
da wollte ich hoffe ich doch ein
bisschen holz mit falls wieder unten
nämlich stöcker brauchen oder cluster
sinn machen ja cool bist du aber möchte
hier zusammenarbeiten so ein bisschen
vielleicht sollen wir schaffen damit
ihnen dass ich im bett machen kann
brauche noch zwei schafe hier sind der 2
praktischerweise so genug power für den
haben wir auf jeden fall da durchbeißen
wollen wir vielleicht auch noch aber das
kriegen wir wahrscheinlich auf dem weg
von irgendwem sich ich habe aber auch
noch 21 sticks also ich habe doch auch
bist du hinter mir habe stopp
joel wieder nacht das ist noch einmal
unterboten wie geht es ihm auch nicht
missen so live hören sein
das war pilz mit dem dann könnte es
vielleicht zu machen irgendwann mal eine
schöne weihnachtskrippe so für
zwischendurch und vielleicht auch besser
so wir spielen ja vanilla nacht übrigens
die zweite folge die zweite nach sowohl
die zweite folge ist der richtige
brocken
die zweite folge ist übrigens wobei mir
die dritte ist dabei komme und die
vierte bei dna nennt er sich endlich mal
melden würde
genau das ist vollkommen korrekt hier
sind auch gar keine höhlen gerade komme
was sagst du dazu
jetzt wirst jetzt sieht hier ausgesucht
weil wir klar weg direkt
ich habe nicht mitbekommen ich habe die
kurve
die täter waren gerade wieder da waren
da war ein schwein eine kuh immer schon
töten
das kann doch nicht sein dass hier
liegen also ich laufe jetzt die ganze
zeit nur in eine richtung ist das war
der längst andere richtung hier
langfristig allen schneider drinnen und
gute mass zuckerrohrstangen dafür schon
mal hingefallen
der nächste zeit aber es gibt gar keinen
federvieh 1.7.2011 dann würde ich einen
reinpacken hero habe ich jetzt allen
drin in hero wärst du das hinbekommen
sind schon tutorial angeguckt das kann
ich doch mal schicken das eigentlich
relativ easy peasy klappt so wir bauen
jetzt einfach mal alles ab weil wir
können eigentlich man kann eigentlich
nie genug kriegen das war's von der
höhle und bin ich dir nur gefolgt hier
eigentlich müsstest du heute bim bus ein
der abbaut weil ich ja aufnehmen
da müsste ich eigentlich so verbringen
das ist von machen dass der der aufnimmt
moment meiner haut doch ihr gemeinsam
ist doch egal ob ich jetzt gerade die
höhle gebremst da wieder raus und dann
sitze ich hier weil die letzten wochen
der höhle ist sich auch mal eben schnell
die kohle ab da macht man das halt so
kläger macht dem asphalt so ok ok gome
definiert höhlen zu machen tun und der
richtige höhe habe ich aber auch wer
nicht gefunden weil er so ein durchgang
und auch da sind kürbisse global service
geringst nicht hin steil aus der höhe
mitnehmen wenn ich mir trotzdem nur
irgend wieder hochkommen ich hab eine
treppe gebraucht
mainz attrappe handicap match ähnlich
harten hunde hund getötet höhe und der
andere und ist böse auf mich herr bereit
der karte erhält er kommt ehrlich runter
das opfer dort konnte aber ich hab's
gesehen ich hab's gesehen komisch da
müssen wir hin dass wir hier so ein
bisschen zurück lauf war ich mit der bim
bam pilze sammeln münzen hat
vielleicht sollten wir auch dieses
mitnehmen damit wir uns eventuell gefahr
machen können ein bisschen brot du weißt
hilfe von crafter wo bist du bist du ich
werde verfolgt hinter der hinter die
rente ich werde hier von hunden verfolgt
umbringen umbringt grohmann ring
ich glaube dass eine hülle oder wurden
hier
damovo findet wieder alle alternativen
zwei skelette beide tot
ich bin ihr schon am eisen abbauen okay
gut ich bin entgehen genau die andere
richtung von deiner seite ausgeräumt ich
bin ein bisschen weiter unten
ich gucke erst mal wie weit das hier
geht ist gerade wasser was austritt das
schöne ist ich muss nicht mehr packen
aufstellen weil wir gerade über
zuschauer hat der kann hier ist zwar zu
ende habe ich es richtig weil ihr auch
ohne kohle und eisen und ich hatten die
theorie
das komme einfach so aussieht wie ich
und dass ich beide kanäle führen dass
ich bekomme man meine stimme verstellen
und wenn du dich jetzt auch schon selben
gang sondern kann in der theorie
vielleicht sogar etwas dran sein
du hast gerade so gesagt ich bin vom
tunnel und bei mir war es genau der
gleichen moment ich auch gerade am ende
das ist ein weiteres indiz dafür dass
ich du bist du ich ja und immer wenn ich
hier so redet dann dann nehme ich das im
nachhinein auf und antwortet mir dann
selber das war eine klasse
ich liebe dich kommen nur richtig liebe
muss man richtig nett auch für meine
zuschauer dass sie so alles sehen können
so richtig gut
ich schaffte mir sowieso fackeln und er
war jetzt einfach mal gegangen bin da
hab ich ja wir sind auch im team aber es
ist mein kann es komme also übrigens mw
wir hatten wieder ein thema zugeschickt
bekommen zwar was sind unsere
weihnachten wünsche dieses jahr dann
soll ich am anfang ja ganz einfach
machen
ja also ich halte meine weil das wünsche
ich dieses jahr sind auf jeden fall für
die ps4 und java so einstudiert
ich war ja aber die ps4 dies zurzeit die
mehr behandeln deswegen kann ich mir gar
nicht so richtig wünsche ja du ich weiß
ich also die ps4 das ist besonders für
etwas
also ich weiß es noch nicht genau
ich habe dieses jahr einmal so viele
wünsche ich habe da er seine sachen für
youtube gedacht vielleicht so etwas wie
go pro oder elgato game capture so was
halt auch call of duty calls oder
vielleicht battlefield für so was weiß
ich noch nicht war mega groß und
wollschweine psp so habe ich dieses jahr
gar nicht ich möchte auch noch gar nicht
die psp haben
bist du denn schon 18 warum kam auf dem
titel wer weiß wer weiß
der kommissar 810 verbietet setzt in
seinen eltern des zu kaufen für ihn und
den weihnachtsmann patente gar nicht
wissen übrigens ich habe ihr neue
eingang entdeckten ja was noch draußen
aber da geht noch mal heftig was mein
geld von mir mit gefunden
wirklich jetzt die suppe machen ich habe
auch schon fünf rote gerade 67 89
die community4you bringen wir bitte buch
raus witzig sein wie komme das tutorial
ich drücke ich mit dem kreis gelaufen
glaube ich hey hallo komme ich gern auch
mal so witzig sein wie du willst du da
sieht es ja nicht mein heck sieht man
dass der welt erwartet
du musst dass du alle deine sachen
megastars junge du musst hier irgendwie
hin kommen wieder ich dachte meine
koordinaten ich leute immer talks das
ist echt toll eingefangen
für lustig sein wie conny einfach die
leute tot prügeln so kommt zu den
koordinaten ich hoffe deine sachen leben
auch wenn du kommst leben noch mal
wieder an
du stellst hinterm ich boxe mich so
einmal der box ich dich da brauchst mich
geboxt
er fand ich witzig schon sagt geht zu
den koordinaten das sind deine sachen
davon ist ein anderer würde da gehe ich
jetzt mal rein
wer bist du blöd die sachen sterben die
sachen sterben hier zwar alle gerade
aber okay
kommerz los also janne korpi fi
ich hätte auch richtig boxen einfach nur
froh zu kommen die jugend ist das
vielleicht auch noch schnell wie man
hier geht es ja richtig steil runter
das wäre es jetzt
du ich hab den einer folge einfach alles
ich wollte einfach hunger du hast auf
100 pro hardcore gestellt nein
also ich hab ich bin nicht mehr weit
gesprintet war mit seinem hunger köln
verloren warum das kann gar nicht sein
okay dann ist vielleicht auch hardcore
metal hardcore display also ich bin
richtig weit ich schon fast die erste
lava gleich geil
komm jetzt kommt all den code zu den
koordinaten ich bin auf dem weg aber ich
finde ich dann irgendwie nicht ich hab
hier quartal einnahmen die koordinaten
geschickt dass auch er noch das ganze
fleisch also ich werde gleich verhungern
hat ist sehr schön klar wenn du nicht
das ganze fleisch ab ach ja ich hab 33
er stimmt ja gab sich am besten auf
meine höhe runter und dann drohen dann
machen wir das einfach mal sachen liegen
ja auf jeden fall bei den koordinaten
liegen deine sachen genommen hat dank
ging auch bei den koordinaten liegen
deine sachen kommen sonst hätte ich die
nicht in den chat geschrieben
119 alter goldener höhle aber nicht in
der mode geworden drin war
jetzt komme ich gar nicht mehr raus [ __ ]
bis zu tun haben überall höre ich jetzt
welche die falsch ich hoffe das war die
das passte genau an wer sind deine
sachen genau als ich bei den sachen
stand habe ich die koordinaten
aufgeschrieben ich konnte nicht mehr
mitnehmen
die gopro wir auf jeden fall so geil
dass ich dann damit einfach so sachen
film könnte wenn nicht dann irgendwie
joggen bin dann würde ich das mal film
oder in die solche sachen im wieder hell
zu mega lust drauf und du komme meinte
ich doch gerade genau das gleiche da bin
ich keine ahnung
solche sachen halt fahrradfahren eine
fahrradtour ist kaum was los war
einfache sachen liegen jedoch aber dass
ein freund wenig hinterlassen ja weil
ich dem wrack in geworden die wir schon
sachen die ränke zu wollen
was hast du eigentlich mehr hinterlassen
ist mein schwert oder hackepeter lassen
du hast bevor das wichtigste wird genau
du hast ein stein von mir ja ohne
fledermaus tierpfleger mich jetzt runter
hier zu dir ich bin ja ein wo hier oben
jetzt gerade und wie komme ich hier und
warte irgendwo es einmal bildet da wir
machen
ich hoffe mal eben gleich zu dem eingang
hin wurde zu mir runter kannst warte ich
nehme doch eben das eisen die mit
bakterien gekommen
vom hoch ok ich komme einfach stehen ich
komme bleibe stehen ist echt auch hier
bist du dran glauben ja das sehen wir in
dieses loch warten hier vielleicht ja
siehst du mich hh
fast tot
da komm ich habe schwer lass es sein
lasst es sein jetzt komme ich habe den
alarm hingeschmissen ich habe dir doch
15 fleisch hingeschmissen
dh wenn du mich jetzt ist alles nur noch
krieg hier krieg im christmas projekt
natürlich ist das ja warte ich die
preise schlag ich jetzt nicht ich geb
dir das so warte hände hoch oder ich
schlage gutach warte ich hab noch das
wichtigste von dir hier kann es noch ein
bisschen kohle geben deine kohle kroulik
nicht mehr eine ohne setzte ihn ein
nachbar
ich habe noch eine schaufel dach man
kann ja auch bilderrahmen machen oh ja
ich weiß dass ich in der nächsten folge
machte das auch noch gut und dann will
ich sagen was auch schon wieder wir
werden in der nächsten folge denke ich
weiter dass er kunden rechtlich wenn das
wenn sie überhaupt noch was zu erkunden
gibt ich glaub ich hab sogar ich habe
wir können langsam wieder an die
oberfläche
ja dann
wir einfach wieder obwohl wir können
jetzt auch eben kurz an die oberfläche
geht mir das ist nicht weit
das team canada mit dem es diesmal
wissen wo wir dann so sind wir hier um
schnell die hoch hier um hier um meine
kohle unterschlagen eingespart da gleich
wissen wir mehr witzig hier sehe ich
schon über mich wundert schlägst und
jetzt sind wir oben ich weiß gar nicht
wo er zu hause geht nicht alter jetzt ne
scheiße man nun geht's nach hause
das das reichste land raum ja das ist
und regionen das heißt da hinten kommt
man ja fast immer schön viel wasser
trinken ja normal
ein ende ist noch nicht weg steht vorne
machen wir schon und boxen den solo oder
süden auf mich oder machen wir schon
eher machen jedoch auf mich alles da
geht auch auf mich der blödmann gott
hilf mir ich habe meinem herzen kommen
bitte hilf mir es tut
du hast die berliner klar erlasses komme
gar nur 13 hat sie alter nur wie
besiegte meine perle eigentlich bist du
als ich das glätte kassiert jetzt auch
erstmal noch um ein gott ein herz komm
lass uns kommen lassen
lasst es alter ohne spaß jetzt nach
hause finden nur zu hause bin ich von
dir weihnacht berdych zum ziel komme
dass es jetzt komm ich höre die bitte
lasst es komme kommen wir die folge wir
überziehen schon wieder kommen
nein wir schmeißen
jetzt geht das cfs arbeiten ich warum
ich habe angst vor dir im hause kommst
nicht reell kollege elik mich jetzt
schlafen ganz friedlich außerdem hat sie
mal wieder den schlaf gewann machen wir
frieden machen wir frieden bringt nacht
wirst du ihn richterin gehört zu knapp
drei jahren gehabt so ja okay gut wie
sehen sie den nächsten folgen wieder
jetzt gefallen hat würden wir uns über
einen daumen hoch freund geschlafen
strecker dein arsch in die kabarett und
dann sehen uns morgen auf dem kanal von
bommel wieder wo dann vielleicht auch
lena dabei sein wird wenn jetzt eine
aufnahme termin finden
und ja ich mag dich auch bis zum
nächsten haus